however someone named Samuel Leeds and
this is Q&A Sunday where basically every
single week I do a video every day but
every single week on a Sunday I like to
answer questions that I've had from the
previous Q&A Sundays so I'm gonna scroll
through find some questions answer them
right now as I'm answering these
questions you might have trigger
questions that you think Oh follow-up
questions or just totally new questions
but anything property related there's
niggling you or bugging you please
comment below right now and as I'm
speaking answering these questions next
week I'll read the comment and I'll
maybe answer your question I'll do my
best to answer as many as I can possible
if you haven't already subscribed to
this channel please do subscribe it
massively helps me and it inspires me to
do even more and better content when I
see that people watch it and also don't
forget to smash that like button as well
I really appreciate that
we've got Darius Morel who says hi Sam
you'll have you ever had to renegotiate
the house price after a survey if so
what's the best way to go about it
Darius yes I have had to do that so
basically when you have a survey on a
property there's different types of
surveys you can get you get a valuation
report so if you're buying a house for a
hundred thousand pound and then you go
and get it valued by the bank the lender
who's lending you the money for the
house then won't say you know what you
buying it for a hundred grand but it's
only worth 90 grand so you're paying
over the odds and we're only prepared to
lend on the basis that the of up to nine
ninety thousand pounds so 75 percent
usually of ninety thousand pound not of
hundred thousand pounds now some people
got our man they got down valued I'll
have to put ten thousand pound of my own
money in to top up the difference that's
a bad move when you have a down
valuation it might be that the value is
just being really conservative it might
be that the they're worried about you
know if it's break today or that the
property market slipping a little bit if
you get down valuation it's a really
good opportunity for you to them
renegotiate the price and I personally
would not want
pay more money than the valuation figure
was if it's a survey whereby it's a
building survey and they've gone out and
have looked at the property and actually
they found some problems with it they
found some some hidden damp or the found
some issues if it's a really big issue
like its structural or it's something
that's just meaning that it's going to
cost you tens and tens of thousands of
pounds to do you might want to consider
pulling out of the deal or renegotiate
in the price so if the survey comes up
with some some work issues then it's a
really good opportunity for you to then
we negotiate the price of course it
depends on what the strategy is you're
doing but I love it when surveys come
back bad I love it when they find
problems I love it when I get down
valuations because it just gives me a
reading and an excuse to them getting
the property even lower so hope that
answered that question all right let's
see what else we have so II 4/5 cream
says house time you'll have a question
when do you know when to sell a house in
order to buy a better house what stage
should you be out when you can do this
so I very rarely sell houses normally
what I do is I refinance them so if I
buy a house and it goes up in value
which means I've got profit I won't
normally sell the house because the
thing is if you sell the house you're
gonna have to pay a whole lot of tax on
the profit that you make whereas if you
refinance the house you have to pay any
tax on that because it's debt you're
just mean livre jingling equity of the
house so when it goes up in value the
profit I take out of that house from a
refinance and put into another house so
I very rarely sell it's tax efficient
and it means I still get to keep the
house rather than having to sell it to
buy another one so that tells me my
strategy hope that makes sense if you've
got follow-up questions on that pop it
below so sue me Dylan says hi I have a
question per property you buy how much
cash flow should you keep in the bank
okay so I don't want to keep loads of
money in the bank because if you've got
money sat in the bank it gets bored and
it disappears so I want all my money or
pretty much all my money to be tied up
in investments which means that my
money's
hard for me it's not getting lazy
setting a bank doing nothing however
it's a great question because should you
have any money in the bank wall probably
yes if it's not in the bank you do want
money that you can access fast for
emergencies so you need money that you
can get it fast whether that's in a bank
whether that's in cryptocurrency whether
that's just you know access to getting
loans you do need to do that and the
reason is is because there could be an
emergency searchers you know if you've
got ten houses and suddenly three or
four boilers all break at once and it's
gonna cost you five thousand pounds just
in fixing boilers and you've not got any
money in the bank and you've got no
money that you've got accessible to you
and you have access to many loans or
anything like that at all then that's
gonna going to cause a lot of stress and
we could could potentially bankrupt you
so I don't have any kind of magic
formula for this but what I tend to do
is I tend to per property I put 10% of
the rent so not of the profit but of the
of the whole rent
I put aside into a little pot which is
like my maintenance pot because you know
residential properties there are always
little repairs and things that need to
happen every so often so I put 10%
besides and then it might be that that
builds up and then suddenly some of it
goes so 10% of the Mint's I put aside I
mean I'm running a business so I've got
lots of staff and stuff like that so I
do also have you know a reasonable
amount of money in the bank I don't
necessarily want to say what that is in
the video but I'll say this it's it's
enough to mean that any emergencies or
problems I'm okay but it's not too much
that makes me feel miserable because I
know that I've got all this money
sitting there back doing nothing when it
should be invested so that figure is
going to be different for different
people but I hope that gives a little
bit insight into how you should view
putting money aside from cash flow from
properties okay another question here
says how would you go about investing in
real estate with a nine-to-five job for
beginners so the great thing about
property investing is it really does not
have to be a full-time thing I mean a
lot of my students that buy properties
and invest in
see they make good money doing it but
it's something that is there do just
part-time on top of their nine-to-five
job and they just do it in the nooks and
crannies of life so when they're on
lunch instead of scrolling through
Facebook
they'll be scrolling through right now
you know rather than rather than phoning
their friends on the way home to catch
up about football they'll be driving
home from work calling estate agents to
booking viewings and put in office
instead of going shopping on a Saturday
and just going around window shopping
looking at watches that you can't afford
you can on a Saturday you can go and
look around houses that you booked
viewings for and put forward offers it's
it's something that you can its it needs
to become a bit cool part of your
lifestyle and a hundred percent you can
do a part time on top of a nine-to-five
job so for beginners what I'll probably
suggest that you do if you're starting
out I would I would say number one is
educate yourself so spend time reading
books podcasts attending seminars over
the property investors crash course
which is a free two-day property
investors program get down to that meet
with people network but also view houses
like get in with estate agents and view
houses maybe even go to an auction just
be really careful but but if you think
from a learning point of view that's
great
so I always say what I'm doing anything
is am i learning or am i earning because
if I'm not learning anything and I'm not
earning anything then I'm not doing it
so just just start just just started
it's never too early to start doing
something even if that's just educating
yourself so Erin Deegan has said hi
Samuel I'm trying to convince my dad to
refinance our house and invest in
property however he's concerned that
it's not possible because his income is
very low and he's only working part-time
digital income effect whether or not you
can refinance a property thanks a lot
okay so Aaron thank you so much for your
question it depends like what I would
say is you'll be surprised because
sometimes I've met a lot of people that
think they can't get a mortgage because
maybe they just assume because they've
got bad credit they might have a CC J
they might have low income and they just
take themselves out of the game or maybe
some people
don't think they can get credit because
they've spoke to their bank and their
bank has said we can't give you a
mortgage so ok well I can't get a
mortgage what I would suggest your dad
to do is to speak to an independent
mortgage broker do you speak to a good
broker it's incredible I've known people
in their 70s get mortgages I've known
people that are really young I've known
people that have got really low incomes
I've got people that have got ccj County
Court judgment and they just think no
way and they can get a mortgage now I'm
not a mortgage advisor so I can't I
can't tell you exactly and it's a very
bespoke thing so you'll need to just
phone up a mortgage broker tell them the
situation and you should know very
quickly if you can get a mortgage but
you say here about your dad is concerned
that it's not possible there's no need
to be concerned you can find out within
20 minutes just phone a mortgage broker
ask the question tell them about a
telling situation and you'll find out so
if you've been to a bank and they've
said no that's just one lender who said
no we can't do it a mortgage broker has
access to hundreds of lenders and then
they'll find someone that can hopefully
if it's a buy-to-let property that you
refinancing they don't really care too
much about your income at all if it's a
residential house that you're living in
I do care more about your income but
please do go and speak to a mortgage
broker guys that's all we have time for
tonight I hope you found that helpful
and useful and educational if you've got
questions you want me to answer please
as I said do comment them below and I
really appreciate it if you would
subscribe smash that like button and
tune in for our next video I'll see you
next time thank you
[Music]